>> IS THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERING MORE AGGRESSIVE
CONTAINMENT OPTIONS LIKE A
QUARANTINE, A NATIONAL CURFEW?
>> WHERE COMING OUT WITH STRONG
SUGGESTIONS AND IT’S BECOMING A
LITTLE BIT AUTOMATIC.
YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE, THEY’RE NOT
DOING CERTAIN THINGS.
PEOPLE ARE SELF-CONTAINING TO A
LARGE EXTENT.
>> ARE YOU CONSIDERING
INSTITUTING A NATIONWIDE LOCKED
ON?
>> AT THIS POINT, NOT
NATIONWIDE, BUT THERE ARE SOME
PLACES IN OUR NATION THAT ARE
NOT VERY EFFECTIVE.
BUT WE MAY LOOK AT CERTAIN AREAS
AREAS, CERTAIN HOT SPOTS, AS
THEY CALL THEM.
>> Shannon: PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUTTING FAITH AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
GETTING HIS OWN HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC A 10 OUT OF 10.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US TONIGHT.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> THANKS, SHANNON.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO READ A
TWEET THAT YOU HAD OUT TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP COVID-19 ACTIONS
HAVE BEEN SENSIBLE AND IN SOME
CASES BOLD.
HIS WHITE HOUSE VIRUS TASK FORCE
BRIEFINGS HAVE BEEN EXTENSIVE,
CREDIBLE AND INFORMATIVE.
HIS OWN STATEMENTS HAVE BEEN
RAMBLING, BOASTFUL, VAGUE AND DO
NOT INSPIRE CONFIDENCE.
GETTING SOMETHING’S WRONG,
GETTING SOME THINGS RIGHT.
HOW DO YOU SUM IT UP?
>> ACTUALLY, SHANNON, I WOULD
SAY THAT TODAY THE PRESIDENT WAS
MUCH BETTER, BUT HE HAS A
TENDENCY TO RAMBLE.
HE HAS A TENDENCY TO SAY THINGS
IN A RATHER VAGUE MANNER AND
THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE -- LOOK,
I THINK THE PRESIDENT GETS
CRITICIZED BY PEOPLE ALL THE
TIME FOR THE STUFF HE SAYS BY
PEOPLE WHO IGNORE WHAT HE DOES.
IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE,
WHAT HE DOES IS IMPORTANT AND
WHAT HE SAYS IS IMPORTANT TOO
BECAUSE THERE’S A LOT WE DON’T
KNOW AND IS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
WE HAVE AND A LOT WE CAN’T KNOW
AND IT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK ABOUT THIS, THE
PRESIDENT INCLUDED, TO SPEAK
WITH A CERTAIN POSITION AND TO
BE CAREFUL WHAT THEY SAY.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU KNOW WHEN HE
SAID TODAY THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS
MIGHT LAST INTO AUGUST, PRETTY
SOON FAUCI WAS OUT THERE TRYING
TO SAY THAT IT COULD GO THAT
LONG BUT WE WILL BE ASSESSING IT
ON A TWO WEEK BASIS.
SO WE CAN’T AFFORD TO HAVE A LOT
OF VAGUE TALK HERE AND WE
CERTAINLY DON’T NEED HIM TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME BRAGGING
ABOUT WHAT A GREAT JOB HE’S
DONE.
HE SAYS HE GETS A 10 OUT OF 10.
I DON’T THINK MANY OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND HIM WANT TO GIVE HIM A 10
LARGE HE HAS LET THEM LEAD THIS
AND HE HAS TAKEN SOME QUITE BOLD
ACTIONS AND SHUT DOWN IN CHINA
WAS ONE.
THE BAN ON EUROPEAN TRAVEL HERE
WAS ANOTHER.
JUST TO CITE TWO EXAMPLES.
SO IT’S BEEN A MIXED BAG, BUT
PROBABLY NOT A 10 OUT OF 10.
>> Shannon: PEOPLE SEEM TO
HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE IN THE
EXPERTISE GOT AROUND HIM.
THESE ARE NONPARTISAN PEOPLE.
THE DOCTOR WHO HAS BEEN THAT
THERE ARE THROUGH NUMEROUS
DEMONSTRATIONS.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING ELSE
THAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> WHEN YOU’RE DEALING WITH AN
EMERGING INFECTIOUS DISEASES
OUTBREAK, YOU ARE ALWAYS BEHIND
WHERE YOU THINK YOU ARE IF YOU
THINK THAT TODAY REFLECTS WHERE
YOU REALLY ARE.
THAT’S NOT WORD SPEAK.
IT MEANS IF YOU THINK YOU’RE
HERE, YOU’RE REALLY HERE BECAUSE
YOU’RE ONLY GETTING THE RESULTS,
THEREFORE IT WILL ALWAYS SEEM
THAT THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS IT
WOULD BE TO BE DOING SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE IT MIGHT BE AN
OVERREACTION.
>> Shannon: AND WHAT ABOUT
THREADING THE NEEDLE?
BECAUSE, LISTEN, IF ARE TALKING
ABOUT TRYING TO FLATTEN THAT
CURVE, TRYING TO SLOW DOWN THE
PROGRESSION SO THAT DOCTORS AND
HOSPITALS CAN HANDLE THIS,
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THAT BEING MAY
BE AN OVERREACTION OF CONDUCT,
THAT YOU CAN STOP THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS, BUT THEN THERE’S THIS
OTHER SIDE OF IT, WHICH IS THE
ECONOMIC OVERREACTION WERE
PEOPLE SEEM TO BE FEELING THAT
THERE WAS A LACK OF CREDIBILITY
THERE, THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING
WITH THE MARKETS AND SOME OF THE
DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING MADE
AREN’T SUPPORTED BY THE DATA.
I MEAN, THE VIRUS AND ECONOMIC
VIRUS SEEM LIKE TWO DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS.
>> WELL, SHANNON, I THINK THAT
THERE IS -- I THINK THERE IS
SOME PANIC OUT THERE AND IT’S
REFLECTED IN THE STOCK MARKETS’
SHARP DOWNTURN, WHICH CONTINUE
TODAY AND WE GET TO A PLACE IN
ALL THIS WERE MEASURES THAT ARE
TAKEN TO TRY TO PROTECT US ARE
REGARDED BY PEOPLE AS FURTHER
WARNINGS OF HOW DIRE THIS IS.
AND THE RESULT IS EVERYBODY IS
SELLING.
I THINK THE SELL-OFF HAS
PROVIDED A GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY
WITH PEOPLE WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF -- SOME CASH, SOME GUTS, AND
SOME TIME, BUT NOT OF HER BUT HE
HAS THAT.
PEOPLE ARE SCARED, SO THEY’RE
SELLING.
IT’S ALMOST CERTAINLY AN
OVERREACTION BUT HAVING SAID
THAT I THINK IT’S PRETTY CLEAR
WHERE GOING TO HAVE A BAD
ECONOMIC ORDER OUT OF THIS AND
MAYBE TWO AND THEN WE WOULD BE
AND WHAT IS NORMALLY KNOWN AS A
RECESSION.
TWO QUARTERS OF NEGATIVE GROWTH.
THOSE CONCERNS ARE WELL-FOUNDED.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING
ABOUT THERE BEING A SNAPBACK
EFFECT AND THERE COULD WELL BE
BECAUSE THE UNDERLYING
FUNDAMENTALS OF THE ECONOMY HAVE
REALLY BEEN PRETTY GOOD.
>> Shannon: IN THE MEANTIME,
HE HAD A BRIEFING WITH GOVERNORS
TODAY AND WE HEARD A NUMBER OF
THINGS TRICKLE OUT FROM THAT.
PEOPLE SAYING BASICALLY YOU’RE
ON YOUR OWN WHEN IT COMES TO
VENTILATORS, THAT KIND OF THING,
BUT THEN WE JUST HEARD FROM
OHIO’S GOVERNOR WHO SAYS THAT’S
ACTUALLY NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
I MEAN, DO YOU THINK THAT THERE
IS ANY ABILITY FOR THIS
PRESIDENT TO GET A FAIR SHAKE,
NOT FOR, NOT AGAINST, BUT JUST
FACTUALLY WHAT HE DID OR DIDN’T
SAY?
>> NO, I THINK THERE’S A PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN SAID ABOUT THE
RESPONSE TO THIS HAVE TURNED OUT
NOT TO BE TRUE.
IF WE HAD A PRETTY GOOD REPORT
TODAY OR PIECE TODAY IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DEBUNKING
THE IDEA THAT HE CLOSED DOWN THE
WHOLE PANDEMIC RESPONSE TEAM IN
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL.
HE REORGANIZED THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL AND TRIMMED IT
DOWN, BUT THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
TEAM REMAINS IN EFFECT.
THE PANDEMIC DEFENSE TEAM
REMAINS IN EFFECT.
SIMILARLY, WITH THIS CLAIM THAT
HE WAS TELLING THE STATES
THEY’RE ON THEIR OWN IN TERMS OF
ACQUIRING THESE VITAL MEDICAL
PROTECTION EQUIPMENT, IT TURNS
OUT WHAT HE WAS SAYING IS IF YOU
CAN GET IT FASTER, BY ALL MEANS,
DO SO.
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS PRESIDENT
DOESN’T GET A FAIR SHAKE AND
EVEN SOME OF THESE GOVERNORS
WITH WHOM HE APPEARS TO BE
WORKING PRETTY CLOSELY WHERE
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE HAVING
TROUBLE -- AT LEAST THEIR STAFFS
DO NOT LEAKING OUT STUFF FROM
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT TURNS OUT
NOT TO BE TRUE BUT WERE UP BADLY
ON THE PRESIDENT.
>> Shannon: TALKED ABOUT GAVIN
NEWSOM, THE GOVERNOR IN
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD NICE THINGS
TO SAY ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND
HE IS NOT A FAN.
LET’S HOPE THEY CAN ALL WORK